[Music]
so in in the in the abstract and the
flyer etc you might have seen my
affiliation sort of associated to Mount
Sinai
but sort of things have changed since I
accepted the talk and and sort of today
when I'm given the talk and I sort of
joined this very large company called
stay-at-home dads for the time being I
left Mount Sinai about a couple of
months ago and I'm working on my startup
while I'm home with my kids so that's
just for full disclosure
the next item business is that obviously
this is collaborative work I'm gonna
talk about sort of - two or three papers
with one sort of paper that anchors
these these techniques but this is sort
of joint work with my great colleagues
dr. Aaron Baum
Joseph Scarpa who was a postdoc in my
group Emily
Patrick and Sanjay Basu who is my friend
at Stanford University so this is not
the entire group but when I was CTO at
Mount Sinai I led both data science
research and products so we have a blend
of sort of PhD level researchers we also
have UX designers developers etc etc so
unfortunately I don't have that much
time and I also burned through a few
minutes put in some context here but I
want to sort of put out some great
resources that sort of do much more
justice to this interesting topic then I
will have a will in the next 40 minutes
one of them is a great tutorial by David
sands I get MIT and Eurasia a lead at
Technion so if you just google ICML
causal inference tutorial it will come
up sort of a lot of the work that I'll
be talking is based on Susan 80s causal
forests obviously so there's a great
tutorial on that as well that she gives
a kdd and elsewhere
Stefan wager who sort of is the
developer of the libraries on github is
fantastic most of the stuff as I
mentioned is from this paper horrible
title very long but was in a medical
journal so - our defense we had to sort
of fit the audience there and the source
code for our method which just really
borrows from the makes calls to that
library that I mentioned above is is
here to get out so for today I wanted to
spend time on three things sort of some
context around the work that we do and
why we pursued this particular
problem and just some sort of musings to
my fellow data scientist in light of
sort of this morning's panel so I added
this actually last minute talk about the
methods about causal forests and and
what makes them interesting but also
maddening at the same time and the
application to clinical trials data so
for context I want to touch on quickly
on three things sort of the context
around data where we stand with respect
to methods and users and how the users
fit into our everyday lives so for for
context for data there's this term I
don't think I invented this term
although I use it in this in this paper
back to two or three years ago of data
empathy where increasingly data
scientist and this is how we learn data
science right we go to da say you see
our repository we download the data set
we've run the algorithms on it and then
when we get more adventurous we start
solving our own problems we go and
scrape reddit we go and scrape medium we
try to build our own datasets and start
doing sort of hacking away at predictive
modeling what happens is that the data
scientists today is farther and farther
and farther removed from a data
generation process unless you work at a
big Internet company and even then it's
still very hard to get to people who are
collecting the data and that puts us in
a lot of trouble because we don't
understand why the data was collected
how and and for what necessarily purpose
at that time and there's a fun story
about this team that was analyzing web
blogs and they found out after
publishing and doing all these analyses
that some for some random reason they
turned off the logging between 6 and 8
a.m. because there was low traffic and
now you have a significantly bias data
so they just never knew about till an
intern sort of fiddled around with the
exploratory data analysis so that's one
thing is that I would hope that in the
next few years and as you guys start
startups graduate from school
really focus on getting closer and
closer and closer to the data source to
really gain that empathy into what the
data we are analyzing and for what
purpose for us to build these promising
methods and and bring these promising
methods really to the forefront of what
we do the next thing is methods and sort
of we come from a history of of
scientific discoveries obvious that a
millennia ago we will look just at
observation observing natural phenomena
we wanted to theoretical anybody who
could put a equation out a few years ago
for me
a few years ago won a Nobel because it
just helped us generalize these
observations then we moved to sort of
more computational simulations and
probably the last century so we looked
at the data driven approaches and most
recently this big data approach but what
has happened what I've noticed now
especially with people graduating more
recently is this issue that we have we
believe in this unreasonable effective
data so this is this notion that if I
have sufficiently large amounts of data
I am able to really reconstruct
fundamental understandings about these
data without having underlying theory
that is I could just mine the data
enough they will tell me everything I
need to know about the world and
obviously this is sort of correct in
certain areas where I'm not interested
in building a theory but it falls short
in other domains as I'll show and
instead of really the main thing that I
wanted to put for background is that do
we have to think about knowledge
discovery today from data specifically
is that it's a mole time it's a multi
methods approach that we have
experimentation we have the simulations
we have the theories we have the
inference and we have the machine
learning we have the big data it's an
essential tool but it's not the only
tool and I foresee that in the future
the greatest breakthroughs are going to
come from this sort of multi approach to
learning and a good example of that is
the Higgs boson when it was discovered
it was a combination of sort of theory
running large scale simulations but also
doing big data on top of that and this
is nothing the way it's gonna go and
finally sort of how does how the users
fit into our day to day routine and I
think this is something that has been a
challenge for me at least especially
coming from academia is that we give a
pass to data scientists because of this
difficult technical problems we say
great job that was a very challenging
technical problem but we do it at the
expense of the user experience at the
expense of actually solving a real
problem that thousands or millions of
users need and I think what I've learned
the hard way unfortunately is that
unless you solve for a particular pain
then you are really just setting up
yourself to write a great paper and
that's that's as far as it goes and
that's what happened to me early on in
my career I've got lots of great papers
won best paper Awards like where I'm at
like twelve reads that's it
unfortunately so
so basically just to summarize I think
these are the the context in which we
are doing data science today that needs
to change the first one is that we need
to get closer to the data source we need
to understand how the what and the why
of data collection and data generation
process I think in defeat while machine
learning soda fizz is what we're talking
about today it is only one part of this
this very sort of complex toolkit for us
to do knowledge discovery in large
datasets and sort of finally unless
we're addressing a problem and we fit
within the users context people are not
going to adopt our tools what I mean by
that for example if you're doing an AI
tool for a physician and you don't
understand that a physician only sees a
patient for 10 minutes and that's it and
you're expecting them to pay attention
to your tool for another 12 minutes like
it's not gonna fly like really you need
to fit within their context and what
they're doing so that brings my rent to
a close but I thought I'll put that sort
of about how we're approaching these
problems on a larger scale so one thing
that I wanted to bring up about sort of
how we we learn data science we download
these data sets and we use them and now
there is this sort of fad about open
data portals it's great we use them to
analyze them but I think clinical trials
is a great opportunity for data
scientists why because people spend a
lot of time curating them they spend
they use what's considered the golden
standard of experimentation to produce
these data sets so I mean you can't pay
more attention to data generation than
that more or less number two there's an
increasing increasingly large repository
of such data their clinical trials.gov
you go there hundreds upon hundreds of
clinical trials they don't they don't
ask the same question I'm actually if
you were interested in diabetes you can
find lots of clinical trials now
diabetes on heart disease etc etc we
separately said there are other
randomized control trials outside of the
healthcare system so for Policy excetera
there also exists and finally it's a
large and growing industry and what
we're talking about forty billion
dollars a year expected to grow year to
year about six to ten percent annually
right so for those that are thinking
about startups a lot of things are
already laid out in front of you
especially in terms of the data assets
and the questions that people are
interested in so the question that we're
trying to tackle is can we add in it so
can
then if I had Virginia's treatment
effects in clinical trials and hces are
very important because they enable us to
identify subgroups I might have
benefited or been harmed by an
intervention
despite the entire population seeming
like there was no benefit right so and
and I'm putting it in this particular
potentially clinical way but obviously
at the end what we're saying is just
audience segmentation right I'm trying
to segment my audience to be able to
show them the right ad apply the right
policy etc etc but in this case has a
medical bench or clinical trial ban so
what's going to drive some of this
conversation about these two case
studies these are very large very
expensive randomized trial so on the
left you have the looking at trial that
was interested in looking at if intense
lifestyle interventions impacted obese
people with type 2 diabetes did were
they better off if we had a strong
lifestyle intervention where you would
help them exercise we will give them
medication etc etc and what they found
is that after a few years they
discontinued because if you look at that
curve on the top right I guess you see
that the control and the intervention
actually the outcomes were almost
identical so they said there's no point
in continuing this expensive trial
instead of going ten years I'm just
going to stop after four on the next
panel here the Sprint trial was looking
at since blood pressure is associated
with all sorts of adverse outcomes
stroke cardiovascular disease etc they
decided to see if we strongly monitored
an aggressively reduced blood pressure
would that make a difference would we
have better health outcomes and the
results were actually where they stopped
every three is because the result was so
obvious yes if I have if I control this
aggressively and I reduced blood
pressure I tend to do better across a
variety of outcomes so that's awesome
great so the question is well are there
subgroups in these two trials that made
up disproportionately benefited or being
harmed by these interventions that's the
question that we're interested in so how
do we identify HT is currently well
there are a few ways the first one is
and the most common one is
pre-registration so before I roll my
clinical
I'm going to say at the conclusion of
this trial I will investigate males that
are african-american and made less than
$36,000 a year if I collected such
information but and they do maybe three
or four of these sort of subpopulations
that are they're going to analyze this
is this is great because now you are not
doing multiple hypothesis testing you
are now your pre-registering these
experiments on the other hand the
computer scientists say well why don't
you just exhaustively search through the
space of subpopulations right so I'm
just doing multiple hypothesis testing
on steroids these are sort of the two
extremes of this problem and so and when
this is untenable as the number of
features grow so when people start
introducing things like fitbit's and
wearables when people start looking at
personal information like people are
making a push like can I look at your
emails in addition to your weight and
your height and your ethnicity as you
add more and more and more and more
dimensions it's going to be increasingly
more difficult for a clinician to
pre-register a meaningful subpopulations
so can we find a happy medium that
accounts for this growing and the number
of data sets in the grow growth and the
number of features while finding
statistically significant subpopulations
that may benefit or be harmed from an
intervention that on average seems to
have no effect or may be positive or
negative so the way we we looked at this
and there are many ways to approach now
this problem it starts out just by
looking at how machine learning
algorithms work so obviously machine
learning the way it works is that I'm
trying to minimize an objective function
a la minimize optimize an objective
function in this case a loss we minimize
it over family function so trees etc
networks and subject to some
regularization where I'm going to
penalize you for complexity
I don't want your model to be overly
complex relative to the data that you
have make sense so but when you take
this particular approach in a causal
inference aspect because what I'm trying
to understand is would you benefit or be
harmed by an intervention and more
importantly for example let's assume do
if I give your aspirin you get better
you don't get better not only I want to
know if I give your aspirin do you
improve but would you actually regress
if I didn't give you aspirin that's why
we can't do this we
a bee test on the real world
unfortunately because there's only one
version of each one of us but the main
and historically how we've been doing
this and I used to do that many years
ago as well is that in a typical setting
where I have my X's which are these
features that are collected about
patients my Y's which are these outcomes
for example did you just die or survive
but then we have an intervention W did
I'll give you two aspirin or not 1 or 0
it's a binary but what usually we do we
just tack it to the X's and there are
many problems with that setting and why
that does not give us optimal models but
most importantly why it doesn't do it
especially in the case when we're
looking at trees we're trying to
partition the feature space is that
you'll find these pockets in the
partition right that will have that will
all fall under one kind of W either all
got an intervention or all didn't get an
intervention so now you can't measure
actually the treatment effect that's
what I'm interested in I'm not
interested in predicting an outcome I'm
trying to understand the treatment
effect and this goes back to the panel
discussion about am i building and
method for the right outcome that I'm
trying to measure and that's what we try
to do here that's why we've went with
this particular approach by Susan
eighteen step and wager because we
believe that it's sort of fit what we
were trying to do best before I proceed
there are many many ways how to find
subpopulation and observational data
there are people who have done to extend
the lasso approaches deep instrumental
variables we're looking at Colville tree
it's called the force but there are many
many approaches and in fact I was trying
to find this great review or sort of
subpopulation identification but
unfortunately I couldn't access my old
work email so it's in the ether
somewhere I'll have to find it but
please email me and I'm happy to connect
there but what's also exciting that a
lot of people here in New York City work
on this problem obviously Adam here has
a great package on causal inference on
github but there's also David Bly and
his former student Rajesh who's now at
David LA he's there at Columbia Rajesh
at NYU etc so the people here John
Lankford who's here also in New York
City these folks are working on this so
you guys could just like hop on the
subway and meet these experts in this in
this particular emerging field so I'm
going to go quickly through this
unfortunately because I can't do it
justice but the idea here that that
Susan Athey proposed in her great penis
paper
that sort of the algorithms are based on
is that she figured that there is a way
for us to transform that optimization
that function that I'm trying to
objective function I'm trying to
optimize from a mean squared error to
maximizing the intergroup heterogeneous
treatment effect between groups so I'm
trying to max I'm trying to identify
groups that will get different extreme
different responses at one treatment or
another and so what they did basically
they set up here as I said is a little
bit different because we have this W
which is the intervention so now I have
an observation whether you survived or
not or whether you got healthy or not as
a function of an intervention 1 or 0 and
what she was able to show I'll just
spare details about what she was able to
show is that actually one way to look at
the heterogeneous treatment effects is
simply to subtract similar users or
participants who got the intervention -
knows that didn't get the intervention
that's the MU 1 X minus mu 0 X and
basically she transformed her objective
function from a traditional mean squared
error to this one where she she gets
this treatment effect you subtracts it
from the observed outcome so it works in
certain cases it doesn't work in others
but since here we are really trying to
undermine the heterogeneous effect the
extreme response of two populations this
actually works quite well for us in
practice there was one problem however
and and sort of this is this is a
problem that we're still struggling with
despite these publications is that on
the one hand trees are extremely
unstable right depending on how what
kind of data set I give it it will give
me a different tree every time so leo
breiman and others proposed this notion
of forests and somebody right here today
was saying that ensemble methods always
are in right so great and boosted
forests you put in any competition is
one of the top algorithms the problem
with with ensembles that they're not
interpretive or like I can't do anything
with them except make a prediction and
this is not what I'm interested in doing
so how can we get the stability that we
get from introducing more variability
from sort of sample bootstrapping the
samples while still remaining
interpretable that I get from a single
unstable tree so here we this was sort
of more for heuristic that we use but
this is an active field of research that
we're pursuing now is can we come up
with a notion of a tree centrality or a
graphs and travelling people talk about
that so if I have an ensemble of trees
what tree represents most accurately the
the behavior of the ensemble and what we
did here basically to give you sort of
an analogy if we were to take everybody
in a theater and sort us by height we're
just gonna ask the person who is the
closest person to the average height of
this entire amphitheater that was the
idea basically what we did we found one
representative tree that performed
similar to the ensemble average and had
most of the features that were included
in that tree it's that great and there's
no sort of guarantees we don't have any
sort of guarantees on this particular
heuristic but sort of from a practical
standpoint that's why I want to talk
about this because it combines the
practicality of sort of some of the
folks that are working more on in
industry the practicality of data
science with the research nature of data
science as well sort of bringing them
together like this morning people we're
talking about in the panel so let's go
back to the look ahead study so they
look at study ask this question do
people benefit from an extreme lifestyle
intervention if I if I help them a coach
do if I made you exercise more eat
better would you improve and people said
no so but then when we run our algorithm
on it we've got a tree that actually
said no there are extreme responses to
this intervention and what we found is
is that there are groups that tend to
have poor mental health and poor
baseline health when they entered the
study actually our responding severe our
responding negatively to the
intervention but they get masked because
they're a minority they get mass by the
population level average so what we
found is that so in that tree in that
breakdown there you find that 85%
actually benefit from the intervention
which is a shame because we had sound
scientific evidence that having an
intense lifestyle intervention could
help a large number of people who are
starting off poorly these are obese
patients with type two diabetes so there
are sort of
far along in a negative outcome and we
are bringing them back which is great
but the 15% mask of that and so what I
wanted to also point out here in this
study what this tree does for you it
just identifies the subgroups it doesn't
do anything else right so number one you
have what you have to do is you have to
make sure that you're identifying the
subgroups correctly you're not biased
you're not overfitting in that sense but
then you need another approach actually
validate your results how do I
independently validate that these groups
are actually real or significant or have
any meaning so what we did since we are
working sort of in morph health domain
epidemiology we use the Cox model just a
simple survival analysis we took their
groups the two groups and we looked at
how likely are their to they experienced
an adverse event at time T and T
increases by year so here it's between
zero and ten years and what you see is
is if you look at the rightmost panels
you have subgroup one where you had the
control group actually doing worse than
the intervention group right which is
good that means that people who did did
this intense intensive lifestyle
intervention improved but then as you
can see in subgroup two the curves flip
the blue improved but the red didn't
improve in this case sort of the control
did better than the intervention these
are the folks as I mentioned that that
started out with poor health and had
scored highly in some mental health
scored poorly in some mental health
questionnaires so what what is the
takeaway message from here as simple as
that well it had the administered this
simple survey prior to the trial they
could have weeded out certain patients
and they could have assigned them to the
right group and what was interesting
about this this paper that made us smile
is that when it got published the people
that ran the original look-ahead study
wrote a commentary about our paper
welcoming sort of us looking looking
again at this dis looking at trial so
that was encouraging for the team and
for myself now if you go to the Sprint
study we said if you aggressively
control blood pressure does that improve
health outcomes
it seems that yes people high-fived each
other they discontinued but then what
we found same story is that actually yes
for the majority there was a lot of
people whose outcome sort of improved
but then there were people who had a
sign foot there was a subgroup of people
these are people who smoked
people who smoked a lot and got this
intervention actually did worse than the
people than the average population and
this is sort of not a small group what
we found out is that there are actually
four times almost four times more likely
to get kidney injury acute kidney injury
based on this intervention so this was
significant especially if you're trying
to run a clinical trial and this this
paper has not been published yet it's
under review at the moment but to
summarize what this really comes down to
is that we found that there are some
clinical trials that have been reported
to have zero effect to actually find a
large subgroup that actually got
benefits from it that we just missed
because we wiped them out in a large
population average similarly we found
that there were others where there was a
benefit a strong benefit actually
endorsed by the the people that run the
study however there were subgroups that
actually were harmed from this from this
intervention and what gets me excited
about this and what we're trying to do
next is that this really shows a new way
to describe enrich in this conversation
of precision medicine so for those of
you that are familiar with this
precision medicine sort of is like big
data like everybody uses that word
nobody knows what the hell it means in
practice but generally speaking with
people when they say precision medicine
they mean combining clinical data with
genetic there can I take these two
datasets put them together and do
something better than with either data
set alone and that's great but I'm
skeptical that actually genetics are
gonna take you that far so for example
we know here if you live in if you live
at there at the intersection between
sort of Upper East Side and East Harlem
right just one block separate you your
chances of dying of cancer doubles right
so we know that genetics cannot explain
these there's a lot of contextual
factors that actually we need to
introduce to precision medicine but one
one thing that we can do as data
scientist is to actually introduce
and better-suited methods to the
precision medicine toolbox so this is
one one sort of example of this a small
example but if we had the same number of
data scientists working in this space
compared to other spaces if you got that
critical mass we will see I think a lot
of convergence and a lot of growth quite
rapidly and I think this is a great
Avenue for actually startups because I
think academia has some barriers that
makes them difficult to break through
here compared to in a start-up where now
the barriers are to Eternity are quite
low so I wanted to wrap up with some
just some caveats there is that
obviously this is a relatively new
approach very unstable we had a lot of
hard times at first getting the model to
run there's a new package on github
the generalized forests package that I
showed earlier I have not used that full
disclosure I think it's like an alpha or
some some really early stage of
production but still I think it's very
useful to look at those I think there's
a large body of subgroup identification
that we just haven't explored yet there
might be better suited methods one
person that I forgot to mention is
Daniel Neil at NYU he used to be at CMU
and he moved to NYU great guy working in
this space from a different perspective
I encourage you to check out his work
and the big challenge that we had was
that a lot of times these algorithms
will find small subgroups right so when
I'm doing my splits I could force it to
say each leaf should have a bucket size
of X that's great
but obviously that anytime you put some
random parameter then you're biasing
your algorithm some way or another so
when we focus on our extreme events
where there was a sign flip but there
could be more subtle events especially
in subtle effects especially in other
domains potentially like I mentioned
earlier policy or advertising etc where
maybe we don't need we might be missing
a big opportunity if we don't look at
smaller effects not these extreme ones
but for now we only focus on sort of
sign flips and as I mentioned before
sort of one of the challenges that we're
facing is that we love ensemble models
but we are having a hard time figuring
out how to summarize an ensemble model
ironically Pedro Domingues
had a great paper about this subject
back like 1998 I'm happy to send that
paper as well where he what he did he
learned the forest and then he sort of
learned the tree that summarizes the
force it was an interesting approach I
think he abandoned that technique but
still he was one of the early folks to
think about this problem and I encourage
others to think about it because I think
it is gonna come up off more often
especially as we explore new domains
medicine insurance etc etc where the
models have to be interpretable to have
an impact with that I am seems early
which is good and I can take questions
and I also be at the party and the
office hour and please feel free to text
me today and tomorrow I'm around I'm
happy to get together with people thank
you
[Applause]
that's my wrong email hi thanks for the
talk I thought I found it very
interesting I have two questions the
first is how did you so in the two
studies you show that you are
identifying subgroups were you joining
on features that were not in the
original study or were those all those
features that you're identifying
subgroups were in the original site to
begin with well we we did a purely
analysis we just downloaded data so I
should have mentioned sorry the Sprint
data challenge that the second study
that we showed there was a sorry the
Sprint data analysis that we did came
out of a community challenge that the
New England Journal of Medicine sort of
commissioned okay and we were one of the
the entrance and then we just took those
results in there but so the data was
there it was collected and we analyzed
it as it cool and then the second
question so I was confused when you were
describing your method of like finding
the like the graph central tree or the
tree that liked best fit the accuracy
lay ensemble because isn't a key feature
of random forests that they like sub
select columns so there's no such thing
as a tree that captures all the features
correct so yeah so we we look at
basically if we were to summarize if you
were to objectively summarize the
performance of each tree by a single
metric it's not great can you find a
tree that has that has a similar
performance to the to the ensemble
basically that's what we did and what
happens is that usually we'll find trees
that are very comparable maybe one is
the single best but it's like by a few
percentage points or whatever it is so
it's not statistically significant so
what we did there we we cheated a little
bit in the sense that we looked at the
top performance we took the most the top
performing one but there were others
that were top k if you will and and we
looked at those as well but it seemed
like the same features were appearing
every time so we actually tried to do
that at first we would just count how
many times each feature sort of and we
weighed those features as importance we
found it not to be very helpful so we
just chose one that sort of performed
but that performed closest not
necessarily the best but performed
closest to the ensemble and we use that
instead so it's not again it's more for
heuristic than anything else but it
enabled us to have that conversation
that it was about sort of mental health
and poor baseline health coming in for
example as they explained sort of the
source of accuracy but you found that
that that that wasn't as invariant as
other others correct they weren't they
weren't as the trees that were clustered
at the top-performing were quite similar
actually with like a few differences
could it be that the sample size with
10,000 data points could be that is just
an artifact of that day is that you do
it again in some other data sets and
that's one thing that we're trying to do
for people that are interested we're
trying to actually now go through every
single clinical trial can you do that
because right now it's quite manual
actually so that's why we're trying to
think about a measure of centrality that
to automate doing these you know across
hundreds or thousands of collage miles
I'm curious if at all you ever take into
account sort of medically inspired
priors about what constitutes a
reasonable set group for the kind of
phenomenon that you're interested in
because it strikes me as an area where
there's a lot of you know existing
expertise about what makes sense correct
yes so so I think they're the two parts
of that answer one of it is that
everybody in my group sort of we really
try to embody this or embrace this
notion that sort of theory guided data
science so everything that we do we owe
by default try to have a scientific
prior to whatever what we do in this
particular case we want to be purely
data-driven in the exploration phase
because while you could compare it to
other sort of known subpopulations for
instance there are two problems one is
that the field of sort of population
health epidemiology focuses on these
sort of risk factors so they know like
at a high level like yeah poverty and
education and these things matter for
example the these social determinants of
health if you will the problem is that
nobody understands how and when do these
manifest and how they interact so it
becomes quite difficult to have to find
meaningful subgroups when we have
interacting factors people will know
very well if you're over 55 you have a
certain risk but when you start
combining these features it becomes a
little these nonlinear combinations
become harder to sort of ground in the
literature at least at the current time
so that so we were mindful of it but in
this particular case we chose to have a
data-driven exploration but then when we
put it in the Cox model put something
that we thought made sense and so if we
had a epidemiologist look into that as
well who's on our team
I have one question so when we're
looking at her new forest we know that
they kind of train to separation
themselves but you talked about the
approach of finding something
statistically significant right and
since not you're kind of deciding the
matrices on your own based on which
you're collecting the final output from
the top of the stack or from together so
don't you think that a probability might
occur that's something which might not
be significant would occur two seem to
be significant when you're following
such an approach correct so yes there's
for sure there's there two risks number
one is that you could create artificial
subpopulations and just because of this
particular data said the way it was
collected that the luck that they had
there seems to be in the data and
artificial population that is
meaningless number two there there's the
there is a challenge in the sense that
you may be able to find multiple sub
population and you don't know which one
to choose right some of them are real
some of them are artifact so for us to
couch that particular issue that's why
we did the secondary follow-up analysis
of doing the Cox model is to take
whatever hypothesis that so then the the
the machine learning model the causal
model is not quote-unquote deployed in
production per se
well we actually deployed it just
grounds us it gives us well this is I
think the segmentation that we need to
look at people that had these particular
covariance then we fed it into the Cox
model and that's technically like the
take home
production model they just said well
yeah it seems that people who belong to
this group actually fared quite poorly
or quite better than the average
population so it's not a great way of
doing it but the fact that we sort of
did it in two steps reduces a little bit
of our risk we hedge it a little bit
that way but ideally yes I would want to
have some sort of confidence interval
and we provide confidence intervals
that's what one of the advantages of
this because trees cannot provide
guarantees I mean leo breiman started
trying to provide guarantees since that
time in early 2000s and we still can
people have attempted but it's not clear
but sort of what Susan ate they did
that's good is that she provides also
confidence intervals and how
she estimated these groups so it gives
us somewhat of a statistical aspect but
obviously statistical significance
doesn't mean physical relevance right
and that's why we feed it into the
second step which is this sort of
survival analysis it's not great but it
sort of was what we had at the time and
made sense sort of to domain experts as
well
[Music]